Boa noite a todos a todas é um prazer
estar com vocês aqui novamente numa
Live vamos cumprimentando as pessoas na
medida que vão entrando aqui pra gente
poder dar continuidade eu queria também
que vocês me dessem uma resposta se o
áudio tá indo bem se vocês me escutam
Boa noite Nila escuta bem a o
áudio me dê um feedback por gentileza
enquanto isso vamos falar de alguns
assuntos e responder à dúvidas de vocês
tem pouca dúvida essa semana obrigado
Carlos pelo pela resposta obrigado
Nilsa Então vamos discutir alguns
artigos tá tem um artigo interessante
falando de uso de luz vermelha com
comprimento de onda e específico durante
15 minutos usar diariamente essa esse
tipo de
laser pode ajudar a reduzir o aumento da
glicemia
após as refeições Achei bem interessante
esse artigo aqui então a exposição
prolongada a iluminação tipo
LED na ausência de luz
solar pode ter consequências deletérias
significativas para saúde humana no
longo prazo incluindo a desregulação da
da
glicemia então eles estão alegando que o
aumento do uso de lâmpadas tipo Led no
setor de tecnologia e ambientes modernos
associado ao fato de que a luminosidade
emitida pelos leds está na extremidade
azul do espectro visível um pouco
vermelho e pode se tornar um problema de
saúde pública então a equipe responsável
pelo estudo vinculado a university of
London né na em Londres e também a
university College London verificou que
a luz vermelha ou seja seria uma
contrabalança aí essa luz azul que eles
acabaram falar que é prejudicial então
que a luz vermelha com
670 nanômetros de comprimento
eh estimulou a produção de energia no
interior das mitocôndrias levando
aumento de consumo de
glicose Então os indivíduos expostos a
luz vermelha tiveram uma redução de 30%
na elevação da glicemia após ingestão de
glicose em comparação com os
participantes não expostos além de uma
redução de 7,5 por no pico máximo de
glicemia então segundo os autores da
pesquisa a intervenção poderia reduzir
as oscilações glicêmicas prejudiciais
então muito interessante uma luz
vermelha nessa frequência 670
nôm controlando o asoca do sangue o
autor principal Dr Michael paer que é
vinculado ao departamento de optometria
e ciências visuais da city University of
London disse é medscape de onde eu tirei
esse artigo que considera possível um
futuro no qual luz vermelha seja usada
na aplicação
eh para controle do diabetes então
através desse estímulo direto que faz a
mitocôndria então se a redução dos Picos
de glicemia pós-prandial depois da
exposição à luz vermelha for
reprodutível em pacientes com diabetes
tipo do essa intervenção poderia ser
usada como uma ferramenta adicional no
controle do açúcar no controle glicêmico
talvez por meio da incorporação na
iluminação doméstica e ou comercial tá
vendo que interessante estão até
considerando não só você utilizar isso
como uma ferramenta de
tratamento o laser aplicado na pele mas
também usar em ambientes domésticos né
para ajudar a estimular mitocôndria e
queimar mais
glicose Então qual seria influência da
luz vermelha sobre as glicemias as
mitocôndrias regula o metabolismo mas a
luz solar influencia o ritmo metabólico
então a produção de ATP pelas
mitocôndrias diminui com o avanço da
idade e também com várias doenças
crônicas então nós sabemos que vivemos
hoje ah no mundo dominado pela luz azul
que embora não seja visível as lâmpadas
tipo LED que são as que predominam são
predominantemente azuis e quase não tem
vermelho né eo segundo a explicação do
professor de neurociência e com autor do
estudo Dr Dr Glenn
eh que é ligado ao Instituto de
oftalmologia da ecl que essa
Universidade também de
Londres então a luz azul que a gente tá
exposto o tempo todo pelos leds eh
comuns né vão reduzir a função
mitocondrial e a produção de ATP
deixando o organismo privado de vermelho
bem interessante né eles estarem
discutindo esse
assunto então a pesquisa estabeleceu que
uma luz com comprimento de onda longo
aproximadamente entre 650 e 900
nôm poderia aumentar a produção
mitocondrial de ATP e a demanda por
glicose Então essa pesquisa começou em
insetos né a equipe já tinha descoberto
que essa luz vermelha reduzia a glicemia
pós-prandial em zangões e eles desejavam
verificar se se seria aplicável em
humanos Então nesse estudo 30
participantes saudáveis foram
randomizados em dois
grupos 15 pro grupo exposto à luz
vermelha de 670 nanômetros que tinham em
média 41 anos de idade e 15 pro grupo
controle não exposto à luz vermelha né
que tinha uma idade bem parecida por
volta de 38 anos então esses indivíduos
não tinham doenças metabólicas
conhecidas não usavam medicamentos todos
os participantes foram submetidos a um
teste de tolerância glicos
né e num primeiro momento depois repetiu
depois de 7
dias então durante o período né o grupo
de intervenção foi exposto nessa semana
por 15 minutos a luz vermelha de 670 Nô
nanômetros
45 minutos antes de consumir a
glicose os participantes do grupo
controle foram posicionados de forma
Idêntica por 15 minutos mas a luz não
era ligada essa luz vermelha não era
ligada Então tudo isso nos leva a crer
que a exposição prolongada à luz azul
sem a presença de luz vermelha é
potencialmente tóxica segundo o Dr Glen
a luz azul por si só já tem um impacto
negativo sobre a fisiologia do organismo
podendo causar distúrbios de glicemia
que podem no longo prazo contribuir pro
diabetes e prejudicar a saúde de forma
global
então a Estela tá perguntando a luz
infravermelha ajudaria Com certeza
Estela com
certeza então estudos mostraram que a
exposição à luz vermelha retarda a
velocidade de progressão ou reduz o
sintomas de patologias como a doença de
paxon e a
demência vi que interessante também tem
esse efeito nas doenças que nós sabemos
tem a ver também com resistência
insulínica tanto paxon quanto
demência também existe publicações
sugerindo que esse tipo de luz reduz a
dor inflamação de osteoartrite nós
sabemos disso também acelera a
cicatrização após lesões no entanto Em
ambos os casos os estudos mostraram que
isso ocorre antes do surgimento de
quadros
avançados Então os pesquisadores
ressaltam que esse estudo que foi feito
com a luz vermelha foi realizado em
indivíduos saudáveis e que ainda não
existe uma conexão entre os dados e
pacientes diabéticos Mas vamos com
certeza fazer estudos pros
diabéticos é uma técnica muito simples
não invasiva não farmacológica e tem o
potencial de influenciar o controle do
diabetes pós-prandial uma vez que
poderia reduzir as oscilações glicêmicas
prejudiciais
então eles fazem uma observação
interessante antes de 90 eh antes da
década de 90 todos nós vivíamos em meio
à iluminação incandescente as lâmpadas
eram incandescentes na sua maioria o que
era benéfico Porque ela tinha um
equilíbrio entre o azul e o vermelho
semelhante à luz solar no entanto existe
um potencial bomba relógio paraa saúde
humana em relação ao envelhecimento da
população com a transição para
iluminação tipo LED a falta de luz
vermelha ou próxima infravermelha em
algumas luminárias tipo LED é uma ameaça
saúde segundo o Dr
Michael explicando que seria necessárias
mais pesquisas para estabelecer se atual
eliminação do tipo LED contribuiu para
aumento dos casos de diabetes Eu
acredito que sim então as pessoas
deveriam ser incentivadas a passar mais
tempo expostas à luz do dia né luz do
sol né existe muitas evidências de que
uma maior exposição di área luz solar
moderada seria benéfica paraa
saúde
bem Pessoal esse é o primeiro artigo de
hoje muito interessante esse assunto
né então se vocês puderem investir numa
luz
incandescente numa luz que tem dem mais
ao vermelho façam isso porque vai fazer
diferença na saúde de
vocês Bem o próximo artigo é um artigo
que diz que uma maior ingestão dietética
de Açúcar está associada ao aumento de
depressão mesmo após ajustar para
possíveis
confundidores isso que indica resultado
de um novo exame de novo
estudo Esse estudo foi baseado em dados
de 18.400 participantes que completaram
a pesquisa Nacional de saúde e Nutrição
do centro de controle e prevenção de
doenças entre 2011 e
2018 ao longo de duas entrevistas
administradas de 3 a 10 dias de
intervalo os investigadores coletaram
informações sobre a ingestão de área de
Açúcar baseada na soma do conteúdo de
Açúcar Em todos os alimentos e bebidas
consumidos nas últimas 24
horas e os níveis de
depressão baseados no questionário de
saúde tipo
pq9 Então os investigadores também
coletaram dados sobre variáveis
relacionadas à idade sexo histórico de
saúde e a conclusão que usou um modelo
estatístico bruto mostrou que a ingestão
dietética de Açúcar estava positivamente
correlacionada com a depressão e o ods r
né a razão de chances era de 1,17 com P
abaixo de 0,01 ou seja esses dados aí de
estatística mostrando que existi essa
correlação
Clara APS ajustar para todas as
covariáveis os investigadores
Descobriram que a incidência de
depressão aumentou em 28% para cada
aumento de 100 g por dia de Açúcar então
cada 100 g de Açúcar aumentou em 28% a
incidência de
depressão participantes que consumiram a
maior quantidade de açúcar por dia
tiveram um risco de 33% maior de
depressão do que aqueles que consumiram
a menor quantidade Então embora os
mecanismos
eh subjacentes associação entre a
ingestão dietética de açúcar e depressão
seja
incertos para eles né Eu acho que tem
muito a ver por causa da inflamação uma
possibilidade é que uma dieta rica em
açúcar pode perturbar microbiota
intestinal concordo com isso levando a
depressão então na prática os autores do
estudo eh escreveram que
diretrizes governamentais promoveram o
estilo de Vida Saudável pode ajudar a
promover mudanças cognitivas e
comportamentais no público em geral e
pode melhorar os hábitos alimentares
reduzir a ingestão dietética de açúcar e
melhorar a saúde mental geral que é um
grande problema hoje em dia né a
depressão tá aumentando demais nos
últimos
tempos eles apontam algumas limitações o
estudo não pôde provar causalidade e o
PH q9
não era adequado para diagnosticar
depressão Clínica também não foi
possível determinar se a depressão
influenciou a escolha alimentar ou
vice-versa então eles estão dizendo aqui
que às vezes a pessoa podia já tá
comendo açúcar porque ela já estava
deprimida né Então essa é uma limitação
do
estudo Boa noite miram Carlos Rocha
Evanete uma pergunta aqui do Carlos
Esse estudo a luz foi aplicado em qual
parte do corpo nas costas
Carlos o estudo da da luz
vermelha um outro estudo investigou a
relação entre a ingestão de proteínas e
a síntese de proteínas musculares em
homens jovens e ativos então que teve o
objetivo de determinar se há uma relação
dose resposta linear entre a quantidade
de proteína ingerida a resposta de ganho
muscular né de
MPS o estudo também avaliou as taxa de
síntese de proteínas em todo o corpo e
balanço líquido de proteínas isso que é
um estudo novo que tá dizendo o seguinte
que existia um limite antes de 25 a 30 g
de proteína que você poderia estar
ingerindo que além disso Teoricamente
você não poderia aproveitar essa
quantidade de proteína Então esse estudo
estudou 3 homens jovens saudáveis e
fisicamente ativos mas não
excessivamente ativos eles participaram
desse ensaio Clínico randomizado Eles
foram submetidos a uma sessão de
exercício de resistência em todo o corpo
e em seguida eles consumiram uma bebida
contendo 25 g de
proteína que é a chamada 25 pro e é
extraída do leite é uma um tipo de whe
Protein ou então 100 g de proteína da
mesma maneira ou nenhum grama de
proteína então três grupos Um grupo com
25 um com 100 outro com
Placebo Então os
resultados mostraram que ao longo de um
período de 12 horas só um minutinho
pessoal que a d an Paula entrou aqui eu
não achei o
ol tá
obrigado então os resultados D estudos
mostrar que ao longo de um período de 12
horas após a refeição a taxa de síntese
muscular de m s foi maior no grupo que
tomou 100 g assim como a taxa de síntese
de proteínas em todo o corpo e o balanço
líquido de proteínas então isso
indicaria uma forte
correlação entre o balanço líquido de
proteínas em todo o corpo e a ingestão
de proteínas relativa massa corporal
sugerindo que quantidades maiores que
antigamente Se achava que não seriam
aproveitadas que seriam desperdiçadas
pelo organismo seriam eliminadas essas
quantidades maiores eh correspondem ao
maior balanço líquido de proteínas em
todo o corpo Então existe essa agora
dados sólidos de que não existe mais
esse limite de você você pode comer no
máximo 30 g de proteína de uma vez Então
os achados desafiam a noção de que
consumir um bolo de proteínas a cada
poucas horas seja a melhor estratégia
como era pensado até pouco tempo atrás
para maximizar o
anabolismo em vez disso sugere consumir
maiores quantidades de proteínas comos
menos frequência É uma opção viável
Então os resultados indicam que h não há
um limite prático paraa quantidade de
proteína que o corpo pode utilizar em
uma única refeição para fins
anabólicos contrariando a suposição
tradicional de que existe um limite que
essa síntese proteica muscular é um
processo que satura
rápido então em resumo o estudo sugere
que ao invés de ser despada proteína
Esso que ultrapassa a quantidade
mostrada para maximizar a resposta de
ganho de músculo em um curto periodo de
tempo pode ser benéfica ao longo de
períodos mais longos então isso reforça
a ideia de que estratégias alternativas
de alimentação com proteínas como
consumir maiores quantidades e menos
refeições podem ser Igualmente eficazes
para promover o anabolismo muscular
desde que a ingestão total de proteínas
ao longo do dis seja adequada Então esse
estudo amplio o entendimento sobre a
nutrição proteica e o anabolismo
muscular sugerindo que há mais de um
caminho para alcançar a maximização do
ganho muscular contando que a gestão
Total di área de proteína seja
suficiente só um minutinho aqui
pessoal
tem uma pergunta aqui da Adriana Doutor
pode tirar completamente o açúcar eu
tirei tudo o açúcar em pacote não entra
mais na minha casa mas fiquei mais magra
do que já sou porque também sou celica
então Adriana come mais batata doce
mandioca iname procura comer carboidrato
complexo e aumenta o seu consumo também
V
de gorduras saudáveis tudo
bem essa que seria a estratégia Mas
Adriana Com certeza o que você fez foi
muito bom pra sua saúde
tá eu acho que faço tudo errado porque
não como carne porque não gosto não
Adriana você não é obrigado a comer
carne não você pode quando você fala
carne você tá falando também de frango e
peixe ou só carne vermelha tem a dica
aqui do Eliseu faça musculação concordo
aqui com a dica do Eliseu
vamos paraas e perguntas Que Vocês
Fizeram no
documento deixa eu compartilhar a tela
aqui com
vocês aí sim el tá
aí deixa eu apresentar
aqui
bem a primeira pergunta aqui da Live de
hoje do documento é do Hugo Boa noite
Doutor você costuma tomar chá verde
camelia censes ou algum dos seus
derivados sim eu costumo tomar o chá
branco preto H long ma o que mais eu
tomo é o chá verde tá ou branco é
verdade que em exesso pode causar danos
ao fígado tem ser um excesso assim muito
exagerado mesmo ser uma coisa assim
absurdamente Fora do Normal então não
seria interessante fazer o uso diário
dessa iguaria milenar Com certeza faz
sentido você fazer uso diário vai ajudar
muito tá bom mas e essa questão aí do
dano ao fígado tem que ser uma
quantidade muito cavalar
viu
pergunta da Renata o que de fato
recupera mais rapidamente o sistema
nervoso e o Cérebro após um episódio de
estess e ansiedade forte meditação a
coisa que mais recuperar rapidamente
sistema
nervoso fazer uma oração com meditação
melhor coisa que você pode fazer para
recuperar desse estresse Ok respiração
profunda meditação e oração
o que que treina o cérebro para lidar
com estresse e ficar forte também mesma
coisa meditação você até colocou aqui
como se libertar das extrasístoles
cardíacas magnésio dimalato elic
carnitina elitaurina
o binol ou com enzima qued são os
principais tá derribos também creatina
tá se com a
musculação pare que pior Então você tem
que avaliar isso tá ou passar com
cardiologista para avaliar essas Extra
sístoles mas esses essas medidas que eu
acabei de falar para vocês são as
principais tá então o fato de você tá
tendo ex extrac com musculação eh pare
temporariamente fazer musculação e vai
fazer uma
avaliação
vamos pra
próxima Marta perz o que indicar em
primeiro lugar para uma pessoa sem
muitos recursos financeiros que ficou
com hipertensão arterial depois de duas
doses da Pfizer um tratamento Inicial
mais em conta em termos de valores
sempre as drogas os fármacos vão acabar
sendo mais baratos
tá mas eu teri uma dica para você se
você puder usar LT anina tem uma ação
anti hipertensiva não muito intensa mas
tem e também ajuda a aumentar calma e
concentração Experimenta
anina 200 mg 3 A qu vezes ao dia tem
vários outros agentes mas vamos falar só
de um aqui por uma questão de recursos
financeiros outra coisa pode fazer tomar
o né mas aí é uma droga medicamento
né agora se foi realmente por causa da
vacina eu recomendaria que você tomasse
pelo menos um nac para bloquear essa
proteína Spike
tá ru Elita Qual que é a dose magnésio
alimentar uma pessoa pode tomar para
aliviar constipação sem prejudicar os
INSS a a você vai usar magnésio citrato
tá ou magnésio O óxido de magnésio é
outra opção
também ou
magnésio tem mais um magnésio que seria
interessante pra constipação além do
citrato o
o o óxido Magnésio e
o me fugiu agora
aqui enfim por volta de 400 mg de
magnésio Element por dia tá mas usa a
forma de citrato que é uma forma que vai
ser mais
laxativa
Evanete diminuiu bastante o consumo de
açúcar mas não consigo deixar o
arroz faz muito ma saúde o
arroz por causa do Arsênio depende
Vanete o ideal é você testar para ver se
o seu arcênio na urina tá aumentado
fazer o exame Ok mas depende da fonte
desse arroz vai ter mais ou menos
Arsênio isso Carlos eu tinha me fugido
cloret magnésio também citrato magnésio
clorit Magnésio e magnésio na forma de
óxido também são as formas mais
laxativas por que não se consegue
manipular nas farmácias sem receita o
quê o magnésio tá
perguntando de nada
Marta Eliseu Live quinta-feira Eliseu
não decidi ainda se eu vou fazer Live
Essa quinta provavelmente
não é verdade que o bikol também pode se
transformar em o bikin não ser ingerido
pensei que fosse o
contrário binon é a forma ainda não
ativa né não metabolizada da da coenzima
q10 mas toda a via bioquímica ela tem
uma possibilidade de ser revertido tá
então se o binol
é formado através da bikon pode
acontecer sim da
binon depois de virar o binol se tornar
novamente o bona todas as vias
bioquímicas tem uma possibilidade de
reversão tem como organismo corrigir
isso e parar de transformar um bqu em
Bona não sei te dizer Eliseu a
possibilidade da conversão reversa
existe mas eu nunca li nada a respeito
disso uma pessoa cujo organismo
transforma binol em binon disse para que
para garantir que terá o binol ela toma
os dois juntos o bikin binol esse método
faz
sentido B vai ser mais caro Elise se
você puder tomar o bicin melhor porque
ele já é a formativa tá tomar os dois
juntos seria uma estratégia de reduzir o
custo de tomar dose mais alto de binol
simplesmente seria essa a situação kavak
10 também pode se transformar em bikin
Ona kavak 10 é o bikin Ona tá não é o
binol
não
eh suplementos Doutor de modo geral
suplementos de modo geral fórmulas
contendo suplementos tá entendi então
isso aí Adriana é porque as fassa de
modo geral com exceção de algumas poucas
tem medo de tomar um processo é por isso
que elas não vendem sem receita tá
porque elas são fiscalizadas algumas
farmácias acabam vendendo diretamente a
consumidor como meu caso da oficial Fama
mas
eh nas minhas informações que eu tive é
que a oficial fma já teve que várias
vezes fechar
e abrir novamente porque que tem essa
questão de ter sido processada várias
vezes quais suplementos potencializam
ozonioterapia
retal não sei
Eliseu Talvez o hidrogênio
molecular Mas isso é uma suposição
tá
bem pessoal Acabou as perguntas do
documento hoje tinha pouca
pergunta respondi à dúvidas de vocês do
documento tem alguém que tá ao vivo que
não entender alguma resposta minha
queira fazer mais alguma
observação ter metabolismo muito
rápido implica necessariamente que irá
metabolizar a
cafeína rápida não depende do de um gene
específico da da metabolização da
cafeína não quer dizer que só porque
metaboliza uma cafeína rápido vai
metabolizar tudo rápido não é assim
não que pena porque suas fórmulas são
boas e gostaria de tomar as que foram
colocadas no grupo conversam com o
pessoal da da integrit que eles falam
comigo que caso a caso tá então se você
quiser fazer a fórmula na integrit eles
vão entrar em contato comigo eu vou
autorizar tudo bem
Ah fruta camu camu e aerola tem
carboidrato suficiente para bloquear o
crescimento do GH caso sejam ingeridas
de manhã não não tem essa esse problema
não Eliseu
elas tem pouco açúcar ouvi dizer que 80%
dos bobos tem como causa esteatose
hepática acho que ao contrário 80% da
esteatose hepática é causada por
obesidade tá os outros 20% geralmente é
consumo de álcool ou de medicamentos
tá É verdade que a indústria usa farinha
de inseto no e protem não não usa não
Vanete o que acontece Às vezes é que tem
contaminantes tá E existe leis
que regulam o tanto de contaminante que
pode ter no produto mas não é que eles
colocam de propósito a farinha de
insetos
não você fez um vídeo sobre suplementos
fosfa cerina recomendando 100 mg três
vezes ao dia pode ser 200 mg três vezes
ao dia pode
Eliseu suco de limão com casca mas
semente de romã aumenta a
testosterona eu acho que não vai
aumentar significativamente
não
Doutor você recomendaria fosf etan
lamina para aumentar a imunidade em
nível
mitocondrial A fosf etan lamina é uma
constituinte
das gorduras da parede celular tá E é
considerado um um precursor aí das
gorduras da parede celular
eh pode melhorar também a membrana
mitocôndria mas eu desconheço Esse
estudo que fala que aumenta a
imunidade mitocondrial aliás mitocôndria
não tem uma imunidade específica
tá eu não sei bem o que que você leu mas
me parece um pouco fora de contexto
essa afirmação aí a força etanolamina
sim é um constituinte importante da
parede das
células é considerado um plasm alógeno
tá então é interessante paraa saúde
sim
Qual os sintomas do detox de metais
minha mãe est usando clorela e glutamax
pode acontecer de D dor de cabeça
diarreia
indisposição problema de pele fica
vermelha a pele tá são os sintomas rheim
mais comuns aí diarreia náusea vômito
dores né de cabeça e problemas de
pele uma combinação errada de
suplementos pode provocar hemorragia
certamente
é possível que isso aconteça dependendo
do que tá sendo tomado e é mais comum
quando você associa algum suplementos
com alguns
medicamentos estou com amebas tomando
Metronidazol Mas preciso resolver a
questão da água desesperada aqui por to
com água é contaminada
Adriana comprou um bom filtro de osmose
reversa
né belez eu consumir ao mesmo tempo os
cantores monel cast Ivete para quem tem
dengue pode não há problema de associar
os dois não num vídeo feito há 11 meses
você diz que um dos sintomas de baixa
testosterona é a
diminuição do órgão masculino você se
refere ao tamanho plasto ou ereto ereto
tem como comer sardinha em latada t
Amarelo junto com algum suplemento que
Cancele o efeito do T Amarelo Não
entendi
Eliseu então Adriana a tua água de posto
deve estar contaminada tem que mandar
uma empresa avaliar isso daí tá você
pode ter tido uma contaminação aí de
esgoto no dentro da água do do
poço isso acontece com uma
frequência Doutor Volta nas perguntas
por você colocou uma pergunta
nova
aqui para
mim documento só tem seis perguntas
tá Que pergunta que você tá falando eu
tô respondendo as perguntas ao vivo
agora
aqui a Volta nas perguntas Será que eu
pulei alguma pergunta
aqui
Ah tá tem umas perguntas que eu pulei
mesmo sem querer aqui eh uma pessoa pode
ficar desnutrida por excesso de
suplementos desnutrida não elizel pode
ficar intoxicada porque suplemento
também eh tem efeito
farmacológico Quais as possíveis causas
para uma pessoa qualquer ter contratura
muscular para vertebral fazendo essa
pessoa ficar o dia todo
imóvel tensão nervosa uma postura tensão
nervosa e uma postura Paula respondeu
aqui
Ah Adriana eu não sei qual foi a
pergunta que você fez sobre água que eu
eh que você disse que eu não respondi eu
tô procurando
aqui
Ah tá tem uma pergunta aqui eh Doutor
como posso fazer com água de poço moro
numa região de Manancial que não tem
água oficial estou com a mibas devo
ferver colocar cloro e colocar o no
filtro de barro eu compraria um filtro
melhor tá
eh você pode ferver a água primeiro e
colocar num filtro bom tá no filtro eu
ten vídeo sobre filtro no canal tá
colocar color Eu não colocaria
não que eu faria era ferver e colocar no
Bom
filtro o melhor de todos é o de osmose
reversa mas é mais caro tem mas tem um
vídeo no canal que eu falo de outras
opções de filtro S procurar lá no
canal Evanete tá usando o MMS para
purificar a água Ah sim Sim essa forma
de coloro tudo bem mas tô falando coloro
comum
tá Qual o melhor tratamento natural para
que quando o meu corpo for eletrocutado
acidentalmente não sofra nenhum mal não
conheço tratamento Eliseu não conheço
mesmo você basicamente quer virar um
x-men assim eu não quer ser eletrocutado
e não sofrer nenhum nenhum tipo de
mal não conheço eu gostaria de saber
também porque eu queria virar Xmen
também qual que era a proporção de
vitamina e total e vitamina
C proporção da
onde como assim proporção da vitamina e
e se onde é que saiu essa
pergunta não entendi Desculpa
Nilsa o senhor recomendo usar filtros no
chuveiro para diminuir o cloro Eu
recomendo Fernando acho uma boa ideia
esses filtros não são caros é por volta
de R
40 é possível dispara somente com chá
sim é possível tá o esquema da rud da
Clark é usa tintura que não deixa de ser
um chá concentrado né e também se Marina
eem outros
elementos tô pensando aqui nos Xmen
ainda vou virar o Xmen aqui tomar um
choque e não vai acontecer nada
comigo Me dá a dica de um bom
laboratório Doutor daqui de São Paulo de
quê de análises clínicas ou laboratório
fmaa
manipulação sim não Adriana Sim eu não
sei se quer dizer com sim eu eu
perguntei se é A ou
B para água de poço ah quer uma
laboratório para analisar água do
poço Boa pergunta não sei te dizer
agora vou procurar saber depois se você
me lembra disso tá doutor você já
utilizou exame coprológico pacientes Sim
várias vezes o coprológico funcional
estendido que o comprom Max são eficazes
sim são eficazes sim
tá cobra a semana que vem sobre essa
questão do se laboratório de Poço eu sei
que tem tá agora eu nunca pedi eu mesmo
analisar então eu não não não tenho aqui
de cabeça
não doutor as nozes pecan tem efeito de
despara tização Sim eles elas têm um
efeito despara de despara
tização tá Nilsa tá elaborando aqui a
vitamina C recomendada juntamente com a
e segundo o artigo científico
Ah sim as duas vitaminas são
antioxidantes a c é hidrossolúvel a e é
lipossolúvel
a vitamina E pode ajudar reconstituir o
ascorbil em ascorbato né porque o
ascorbato né quando ele entra em contato
com os radicais livres ele vira ascorbil
então a vitamina E pode ajudar
reconstituir a vitamina C ela se tornar
novamente um agente redutor e não
oxidante
eh mas é bem proporção eu nunca li nada
falando de proporção entre um e outro tá
e a vitamina E não é uma vitamina única
são oito vitâmeros né tem os tocoferois
quatro tocoferois e quatro tocotrienóis
Então vai depender se tá com deficiência
ou não de vitamina E porque a vitamina E
em excesso também dá problema
princialmente o ofto
coferol tá então se você quiser ter uma
segurança maior toma toco trienal de
Urucu 100 mg por dia toc trieno
Urucum vitamina C você pode tomar por
volta de vai depender muito mas pode
tomar 500 mg duas vezes ao dia mais ou
menos
isso esses hormônios que vendem farmácia
comum são seguros hormônios que
hormônios Fernanda você tá falando de de
bioidênticos tem vários que são seguros
tem por exemplo o estradiol que é um
estradiol bioidêntico que tem na
farmácia tem a Utrogestan que é a
progesterona também é bi idêntico tem
vários que são seguros tá o que eu não
recomendo são
sintéticos essa vitamina C ela passa
muito rápido pelo organismo muito
rapidamente eliminado tá a lipossomal
não vai durar mais tempo elá só vai ser
melhor
absorvida
toxoplasmose tem vários tratamentos tem
o tratamento convencional com
eh antibióticos né que são da
classe me deu um branco agora da classe
do qual que a classe dos antibióticos
para toxoplasmose tem muito tempo que eu
não trato isso mas existe tratamentos
até com fitoterapia e também com
homeopatia tá existe agentes
homeopáticos para tratamento de toc
plasmose que é uso toc plasmo super
diluído excesso de eg6 pode provocar a
contratura
muscular não não vai provocar pode
contribuir mas não
provocar
Obrigado Adriana pelo seu comentário
carinhoso aqui bem já estamos indo para
45 minutos de
Live respondi a sua pergunta Fernanda
era isso que queria
saber
ótimo obrigado então pelo seu feedback
Fernanda pessoal então vou encerrar
agora porque senão fica vídeo muito
longo depois vocês não vão querer
assistir tem alguma pergunta que eu
pulei
aqui ah tem uma pergunta aqui do
Eliseu tem
aqui sardinha e azeite de oliva no
Mercado Livre seria mais saudável sem
dúvida viu Fernanda bem mais saudável
num vídeo você fez recentemente você
recomendou folhas de dente de leão para
ajudar na digestão ol essencial de dente
Leão quando o ingerido produz o mesmo
efeito sim mas tem que tomar cuidado
para ver se o fabricante ele homologou o
produto para ingestão
tá obrigado ivanet pelo comentário
obrigado
Boa noite para vocês progesterona tem
alguma sim ultrogestan ultrogestan você
acha na farmácia comum mas eles não vão
te vender sem
receita vou responder essa última
pergunta do eu tô saindo pessoal quando
a pessoa ingere cloridrato de betaína
mais pepsina mais enzimas no almoço ela
pode se dar ao Luxo de esperar menos de
1 hora para beber 1 l de
água pode
dependendo da digestão da pessoa pode
muito obrigado pessoal boa noite até a
próxima